you say cyrus est bien dans cette vidéo
un petit peu spéciale on est dans un
cadre assez estival check ins et
christique voilà comme quoi ça arrive à
tout le monde
je voulais vous dire quelques trucs déjà
ça fait longtemps qu'on sait pas vu ça
me saoule
donc voilà je voulais faire cette vidéo
pour vous parler un petit peu recrée du
lien parce que ba ba vous comptez
beaucoup quoi vous avez vous compté
beaucoup pardon et même s'il ya facebook
twitter et que ça c'est pas la même
chose sur youtube parce que ben je suis
un youtube à la base et vous êtes plus
nombreux la et et les commentaires enfin
le lien qu'on a là il est pas pareil sur
deux plateformes à chaque fois c'est des
liens différents
en fait les bref celui de youtube ça
plante donc ça manquait et il ya
différentes raisons à ça j'ai fait qu il
pas eu beaucoup de vidéos je vais pas
rentrer dans le détail la maintenant
mais ans au concours danses de
différents trucs les formats qui qui
allait pas tu vois par exemple ça juste
lipse tu vois le truc sur les païens
peppers et bien il faut sortir vite et
donc du coup ça devient une priorité par
rapport à d'autres trucs
donc du coup ça prend place sur le coup
de fil etc et georges effet un
c'est sûr nuit de goût par exemple que
gm sorti tu vois gens ça m'a pris grave
du temps heureusement j'ai sur sa vie si
je suis passé à l'usagé des co auteurs
et ou qui mettent des potes mais mais
même ça c'est assez complexe
nous voilà ces trucs que j'essaie de
faire en sorte que la rentrée soit pas
comme ça et de pourra vous sortir
beaucoup plus de vidéos à la rentrée et
c'est pour ça aussi que bah je fais une
sorte de petite pause je pars je dis
c'est de partir à la fin de la semaine
je pars pendant trois semaines à plus de
7000 kilomètres d'ici et je parle dans
une sorte de retraite spirituelle
j'essaie de vous en faire une vidéo très
sympa
je vais donner mon max et je fais un
making of en live du de cette vidéo là
sur sa plate voilà donc en fait sur
snapshot je filme et quand je serai là
bas je viens voilà donc là je sais pas
moi je faire tel plan rejeté l'idée est
bien et en plus je vous partager des
trucs un petit peu culturel un petit peu
vlog que je ferais pas que je mettrais
peut-être pas dans la vidéo parce que
j'ai pas envie de faire un blog de
voyage je pense pas enfin bref donc
voilà je préfère vous prévenir en amont
en fait pour ça je fais cette idée en
amont avant de partir parce que je parle
de trucs à faire avant de partir il faut
que je termine faut que je boucle pas
mal de choses mais voilà ça me tenait à
coeur de vous dire que sur snapshot je
ferai une sorte de making of en live de
2,2 cette vidéo de cette vidéo là à
l'étranger quoi et donc ça peut être
hyper cool donc venez venez est la
dernière chose que je vais vous dire
c'est qu'il ya quelques mois j'ai fait
un projet j'ai commencé un projet avec
avec google en euros j'adore l'art je
suis un gros fan aussi nouvelles
technologies et google m'ont appelé
m'ont dit est ce que tu as des trucs à
dire sur l'art et les nouvelles
technologies
je fais grave j'ai fait plein de trucs à
dire sur la nouvelle technologie et du
coup on a fait une vidéo qui est sur
leur chaîne
la chaîne google art et culture c'est
une vidéo en anglais
donc c'est un petit peu un challenge
pour moi mais je suis assez content du
résultat en fait et je les partage et a
pas mal d'entre vous via facebook
twitter c'est un plâtre et tous les
retours que j'ai eus sont plutôt
positifs pour l'instant donc à la merci
beaucoup
et voilà je mets le lien dans la
destruction est ici quelques pas je sais
pas encore et voilà j'espère que ça vous
plaira ça parle de synesthésie donc le
mélange d'essence et de cybernétique et
cetera
voilà qui sont des sujets que je trouve
passionnant voilà je vous à peu près
tout dit j'essaie de faire assez vite
parce que je voulais pas fait une vidéo
hyper longue surtout pour pas dire
finalement grand chose
voilà vous manque et que vous inquiétez
pas il ya des vidéos qui vont revenir en
force
le coup de fil que ça s'arrête pas du
tout il ya un coup de fil qui est prêt
je peux même vous dire que c'est sûr
schopenhauer qui est donc ça va être
assez intéressant
et voilà ajoutez moi sur snapshot
poursuivre ce voyage qui va être
j'espère assez fou chasse excité en fait
j'ai un parti aussi loin aussi longtemps
seul donc je suis assez excité et
j'espère qu'à pas un contre jour un peu
relou voilà et voilà passé 1 et est donc
allé voir la vidéo la vidéo que j'ai
fait et google qui à mon avis ce sera
cool donc je vais repartir dans ce sens
là parce que le soleil c'est mieux que
je me plains deux mois d'ailleurs malgré
la barbe et la casquette militaire vous
rassure je vais pas du tout en syrie et
d'ailleurs ce que je vais mourir ses
voiles a passé un très bon été malgré la
morosité ambiante
je parle avec des potes hier et on
parlait d'une sorte de métaphore avec la
mouche et l'éléphant voyageurs un
éléphant il est hyper balèze il est
hyper solide et une petite mouche qui
vient en fait la mouche est vraiment
l'oreille et donc c'est tout petit
message n éléphants il bouge et fait
n'importe quoi eh bien eh ben soyons
l'éléphant mais je dire tu vas bougeons
pas trop ayons sa sagesse la sagesse de
l'éléphant voilà c'est un peu nul c'est
la pire métaphore que j'ai pu sortir
je pense que vous avez quoi je pense que
vous avez compris l'idée je pense que
vous avez compris l'idée vous allez être
indulgent avec moi voilà je fais de gros
gros bisous vous envoie dû laver de la
piste